maybe the place to begin is with limited
liability joint stock corporation which
is as mysterious in many of its workings
as any religious icon and as as powerful
and as dangerous in some ways as can be
imagined beginning corporate corporate
entities go back to the ancients and
corporations chartered by governments go
back to early modern times but the
limited liability joint stock
corporation as we know it became
important only in about eighteen sixty
the Jim Alexander had a distinguished
career in managing the affairs of joint
stock corporations this economic forum
accounts for roughly four fifths of all
the wealth created in a capitalist
economy and if you squeeze hard you
might get to ninety percent but
certainly it is the principal
organizational medium in which wealth is
created it has several peculiarities of
which the most important is that the
owners have essentially no way of
controlling the business or even really
knowing what the business does the
displacement right if you think about
the classic marks a story about the
bourgeoisie and the proletariat it's
essentially a dualistic story about
classes and with the joint stock
corporation a third-class managerial
class of which MBAs trained at Yale and
and also at the Harvard Business School
are exemplars of the highest order and
so you've got enormous enormous power in
the hands of a managerial class and
Jim's experience which I'm going to get
him to begin recounting momentarily
momentarily illustrates the terrific
complexity of value realization in the
sense that miroslav was sketching within
the framework of the joint stock
corporation now and the dramatic case of
course is with the subsidiary or
majority held majority Enron held
company called Enron global pipeline and
power of which jim was chief financial
officer officer at the time that the
crooked he was twisting crooked Jim you
were a Yale undergraduate finishing in
72 73 73 I'm aging him beyond his date
beyond his years and somewhat unusually
went straight to the Harvard Business
School to law school or med school so
having a primitive sense of markets I
avoided where the crowd was going and
when elsewhere were you there Chet you
were probably there just after President
Bush 43 you know I think he graduated a
year or two in front of me right he was
three years ahead of you here yes yeah
and how do those two experiences compare
for you neo college HBS well that's a
good question I you know college was a
very different collagen is today yo
college was a at the time I was actually
someone probably well a right-of-center
which interestingly enough now puts me
left of center at least as far as I can
infer from the people going to yo
college now in terms of the interests at
least that I'm seeing at the time they
were and I'm not presupposing which are
superior by any means but there was a
drastically different orientation
orientation away from material goods and
orientation toward the other broadly
construed and desire to serve society at
the time being somewhat of a meandering
wastrel I didn't go down the path of
serving others but concerned about
maintaining at least an upper
middle-class lifestyle which I've been
raised in went to HBS and started
realizing how different a lot of society
was from the Yale College people that I
knew so it's it's very very smart
razorsharp people at HBS and but the the
razor metaphor probably applies in lots
of ways and I wasn't used to dealing
with such individuals at Yale College so
you mean people what had was a stronger
moral or ethical sense here than there
how could it be virtually no one
actually that I was a friend of mine
approved my going to HBS and but then
again most of my friends I decided
weren't exemplars of good judgment so i
ignored their I ignored them but it was
it was sort of a shock I think one of
the things that at least my parents
didn't do they didn't tell me about sex
and I didn't tell me about what people
will do for money that's a showstopper
of a line the well let's talk about what
you did for money only not sex so
straight out of HBS you found yourself
in well I I having no common sense I
couldn't go into marketing and so I end
up gravitating into finance and
accounting which at HBS doesn't doesn't
even require basic statistical skills
either it's more of a its taught by the
case method and so I found that
relatively simple to do but again it's
my comparative advantage over all I was
inferior student however I did get a job
and I went to work at a very happy
experience Edna Life and Casualty before
before insurance companies changed their
points of view as to how to run
themselves it was it was a very
beneficent environment and a really a
joy to work in so my then wife announced
either we could leave Hartford her she
could leave Hartford thus starting my
backward entry into Investment Banking
okay and that so you left Hartford
together apparently yeah and you found
yourself in New York yes and kuhn loeb
fine old soon-to-be-dead investment
banking firm but typical of the
investment banking that developed after
or as part of the the cleanup of the new
deal but I was privileged to be able to
see him as banking as it was in the 70s
which is before the great decline okay
and the dominant organizational form
then was still the partner partnership
absolutely with partnership type of
thinking where you commit the
partnership and you have a general
liability and if something goes wrong
everyone suffers and it's not sort of an
anonymous group of shareholders that you
don't know and could care less about
suffering it's you and your friends and
your family okay mark that that's a big
point about the organizational form of
business enterprise and the historical
structure of the ibanks was partnership
so that if one partner creates a
terrific problem it belongs to every
partner they are all jointly and
severally liable and the evolution over
the last 25 years has been away from the
partnership structure toward the joint
stock corporation on Wall Street so if
you don't have liquidity also you have
to worry about long-term value creation
right so having so not having to worry
about the liabilities created and not
having to worry about the long-term
wreckage both reinforce short-term
thinking which is then further
reinforced by the fact that most the
investors have no idea what you're doing
either so it's just a recipe for
disaster okay so after kuhn loeb where'd
you go chan loh promptly emerged out of
existence and was absorbed into lehman
brothers and my uncle who was a client
of Lehman assured me I should under no
circumstances work at Lehman and so I
went to work at first Boston later to be
absorbed into credit suisse that's the
common theme of every place I've worked
off a whole lot of business basically
so Matt through Mike okay so and through
that period was your life at work did it
didn't feel comfortable and productive
for the most part yeah it was productive
I felt productive I didn't tend maybe
because I was associating with the less
successful people but I didn't tend to
associate with people who are really
going places I sort of tended to
associate with for the plotting partners
who merely tried to do a good job by
their clients soon to be lost to the
flotsam and jetsam of investment banking
so I associated and by luck with people
that actually were nice but is it you
know they're they're the losers in at
least the last 30 years ok so the
implied judgment there about the the
upper crust of the financial world
sounds pretty negative it is negative I
think we've forgotten I think the
ideology which is swept the country is
has been one of the unfettered pursuit
of self-interest with and without any
interest in other people is somehow
productive and my experience has been
just the reverse what they're talking
about organizations are talking about
markets I it just simply doesn't work
and i think the the i think the New Deal
actually came up with lots of good
changes the ignoring of which has led to
the series of panics that we've had the
ignoring or repeal it you have in mind
particularly glass-steagall or a glass
glass steagle would be one the exempting
of certain types of derivative trading
from the CFTC regulations would be a be
another the general d regulatory zeal
which would take in a once-proud sec and
make it
letter is as another example where these
people started believing the baloney
about markets being so wonderful and
maybe certain markets and certain
limited ways are but the way it's been
extrapolated mindlessly is led to even
the regulator saying well you don't
really need us and as a result sleep at
the switch the ultimate versity of
course is when certain people say you
don't need the regulator because the
regulator's proven that they can't stop
the worst excesses when in fact the
regulator couldn't stop the worst
excesses because of the deep regulatory
zeal which basically squeezed on the
budget so unmercifully the known of
inequality would even go to work for the
regulator it's all incredibly twisted
and but I the SEC was a fine institution
which really was important and it's
amazing that it was allowed to basically
died on the vine so let's get from first
Boston to Houston what what were the
steps there oh the steps are that I was
in what's called the project finance
group which was designed to get things
off balance sheet and I started getting
sort of queasy about what we were doing
but I'm you know on not not queasy
enough probably to go the SEC even
though what we were doing was consistent
the accounting rules any case I decided
I wanted to get out of out of project
finance and I went to my boss and said
look I really elect to get into
corporate finance which is more straight
representation of clients and not sort
of a transaction wearing at a type of
discipline and I was promised that would
happen and then I started getting strung
along for a couple years so ultimately
I've I decided I wasn't getting in
corporate finance at first boston and i
joined lemans energy group and the first
day I was at Lehman I remember and I
went over the
my uncle told me not to do it like it
was too smart I ignored him I remember
the first day I was at Lehman I was in a
partner's office and he was just as
happy as I ever saw him the entire time
I was at Lehman the reason why is he had
gotten an assistant treasurer fired and
he was chortling at this display of
control lowers client the reason why I
was important to get this assistant
treasurer fired is because the assistant
treasurer was correct in complaining
that he had overcharged the client this
person has since going on to be probably
a billionaire and that's the sort of
person who won in the course the last 30
years and that's the only reason I even
do any of this stuff is because I really
don't even like talking about business
anymore because it's so upsetting but i
but I want to alert people to the
trade-offs when you start to enter this
world you change unless you are very
strong and what happens up happening is
that any of the values you had which are
not completely dictated by money wither
and die wow so this is a truly corrosive
environment now Fred yes they have have
a counterpoint he wants to raise
president and I think your attitude
would change slightly dark because the
story is it wasn't is quite different I
don't you new york life as Investment
Banking that's a separate mmm more
specific okay my experience is only with
banking whether corporate banking or the
universal bank this wasn't the point I
was going to make the point I was going
to make is he talked about people change
in that environment and I would suggest
if his top management as a strong values
doesn't allow you're not going to see
the kind of pressure maybe that you saw
you know is someone coming in it the
only place where I saw Tom management
having any sort of value system was at
Goldman Goldman had it i'm not saying
what they have now but at the time they
did every other place I worked the
higher you looked up the more corrupt
people think management imited talked
about and enforce those and I'm also
saying when i worked at aetna which is
the closest I came to New York life that
that was a great place to work and that
was from 75 to 78 but that was a great
place to work and I had friends worked
various insurance companies and they
didn't experience the same thing but
what I see at Yale College is a lot of
people who are desperate to get on to a
trading desk or desperate to go to work
in investment banking and I'm saying if
if one already had a point of view where
people really weren't important or even
better you didn't like people but you
loved money then you're perfect and
don't change and that's what you should
do but and but if you really do have
other values think about what's
important and don't and at least don't
let it happen unconsciously because
there's no edge you can come to this a
lot of people think they come to the
edge and they look
I'll know it's an egg so it's a
continuous curve down all of a sudden
there's no stability to where you're
trying to stand but at that point it's
very late to come back and that's and
and it's but I am accepting the
insurance companies TIAA I a lot of
people used to know they're so anyway
that's it's it's it's really that's why
I want when I say a wandered into
Investment Banking most investment
bankers are hard-charging guys who one
of her girls want to go into Investment
Banking I went as part of a non solution
to a marital problem because it after i
went to us and banking i was working 80
hours a week hundred hours a week and of
course I thought if I just kidding aside
I got a class class so mr. Radford
University was in class I leadership of
the business I told all this to mandir
all either graduating or signal Gregory
and I told all the students they're only
like 18 students I said you can go I'm
happy to give you a place after this
course is over and at least happen they
all wanted to get investment and just
support what you're saying at least half
of them have called emailed me sentence
is a two-semester people with with
ethical issues where they were being
fresh even at a very low level in the
organization to do something they
violated their own value system good for
them what's good good for them to email
you that's what I would say that they
have enough concerns left in life that
they would still stumble oh no this is
this is great it's it it gives me hope
this is terrific but I part of my job
here is to get us oh yeah thank you Sam
yeah you start off in Houston as a
consultant basically well after in after
my last job where the head of the firm
announced I had a quote on economic
attachment equality unquote I decided to
take take my quixotic approach to the
business and just started doing
corporate finance consulting to my old
clients with a
put me on an annual retainer so I was
the one person who didn't have a
short-term self interest in a fee one of
my clients had been Enron we've done a
lot of work for them when they had
emerged from from the merger of Houston
natural gas and inner north and the head
of the financial area there was a good
friend of mine asked me to come help
them sort of be able to sift through the
endless suggestions by bankers they were
getting I did and within a month or two
they put me on a project to roll up all
of their international projects into a
new company sell a little less than half
of that company to the public and then
have it be their future acquisition
vehicle for for international projects
okay and this is imran global pipeline
and power yes and so the the Enron
controls 51-percent yes and after the IP
after the initial public offering 51%
right and so you've got a lot of these
anonymous investors out there and some
of the perhaps not so anonymous mostly
anonymous investors yes okay no one no
one no one upgrade no big institutional
okay and part of or in a sense the
fulcrum of your of your challenge is
that the interests of the minority
investors are potentially at risk if
Enron exerts undo control over the
apportionment of costs and and accrual
of benefits in this enterprise right
because if you just do the math of Enron
has a 10 million dollar expense which
has at least a colorable basis of trying
to get my little subsidiary to assume if
my city of subsidiary assumes that they
only have to pay 5.1 million dollars
fifty one percent of 10
as opposed to 10 million out of 10
million so anything that that one could
was a semi straight face argue we should
pay they try to get us to pay and I mean
we're in any relationship between two
firms there's some pulling and hauling
of that kind right but in this case
there was an opportunity for innocence
self-dealing absolutely whether it was
always going to be a lot of transactions
with affiliates which didn't bother me I
expected that what did surprise me is
instead of having me negotiate with on
an even basis with my with affiliate
management I ended up negotiating with
my immediate boss who represented and
Ron's interest against his own against
the company's interest so the CEO of
pipeline and power is an Enron guy yes
and you you end up being the voice of
the minority shareholders yes and the
tussle is is not an even one no no it
wasn't designed to be even as does it
was designed to make it clear that any
self-interest I had should be involved
in in Ron's behalf okay so maybe it
maybe it would be useful if you
recounted how you first got to feel
extremely uncomfortable with us well
couple months after the initial public
offering we were going down to Argentina
to look at the pipeline system down
there and the chief operating officer of
Enron started to talk up the Dominican
Republic project which didn't surprise
me I mean that was we knew that was one
of the next things they're going to try
to sell us and
I was just about to go through the
counter to these various arguments as to
why it was such a great project and as I
was just after just after I'd said well
from EP peas point of view not just
about to reel off why frankly his
arguments were fallacious he screamed at
me from about two feet away it was a
small jet two feet away that's what's
wrong with this company it's always me
my me my and so it went on for maybe
somewhere between 30 minutes and 45
minutes someone you know a little bits
of spittle hitting me occasionally for
so that should have been an indication
to back off unfortunately I was I
labored under some extra problems and
that is that my father had been
commissioned the i arrest you in the
Nixon years and had stood up to Nixon
and his henchmen and I wasn't gonna put
a blot on the family discussion by
agreeing with Isla sleazeballs okay so
that the inculcation of values of the
kind that this course is most concerned
with came not at Yale College and
certainly not at HBS negative it at HBS
somewhat at Yale College and mostly
between about the ages about 4 and 12
yeah and it my own guess is that I mean
one inference from that and it's and it
fits my own beliefs is that the
fundamentals of values and ethics by and
large precede formal education they can
be sharpened honed made deeper reg but
if they're not there at about age 10
they may not be there for age 60 right
so the large maybe it'd be useful if you
gave us just a sketch of the larger
setting of where you live who your
friends are
how the how you're I mean at the time
when I was at the time you were dead rod
in Houston well Houston is a very
corporation business oriented place
where until it cratered Enron was
idealized idolized it was just the icon
of everything good about America and so
there weren't any naysayers that it
emerged from Enron at that point so one
of the things at least I looked at was
that no one I just started complaining
to my wife who I think it was forced to
believe me but none of my friends
believe me my father never years old the
stock you know so so and that emerged
later actually after I had lost my job
and I was completed grouse about Enron
occasionally I'm called a house of cards
and people would say Oh Alexander you
just lost another job it's just sour
your typical sour grapes so do but the
upper tier of executives all live in
more or less the same place and belong
to the same club yeah yeah i ken Ken Ken
Lay was my sponsor for membership at the
rib roast country club so that you know
so all the same you know same area of
town same sort of social circles but
beyond that it's also sort of a a sort
of a problem in this is why I believe
that whistleblowers really should get
there should be an equivalent of the
False Claims Act or whistle blow
corporate whistleblowers is that if
you're a whistleblower which I'm not
declaring myself to be you should be
able to get paid basically because
you're going to basically be
unemployable right because even though
everyone's cut Tut's you know Enron the
fact is is they don't want people
at least in this is the group if I was
familiar with and whether its investment
banking or the or a lot of the energy
companies that I was familiar with they
really don't want to have people walking
around making charges right so it's a
matter of fact when I talked to one of
the board members of EPP will the one
outside board member that I felt had
True Grit true intelligence he said I
don't want to hear about it that's when
I that's when I decided Jesus you know
I'm maybe I should go quietly into that
good night well let's just stop and flag
the fact that the costs of integrity
here would be measured not just in money
and employment opportunities but also in
the pressures of daily life in what it
would be like to go walk in the bar at
the river oaks country club and what
what for the those forces were I assume
palpable I could deal with I could have
dealt with the social forces it was more
than I literally believed that I would
be unfit for employment in the any of
the fields I had worked worked in to
that point I suppose I could have gone
back to the bond investment department
of that no but i think they folded it by
then so but that's that's really what i
confronted basically all the work I'd
done would be lost but in actual fact
you made what turned out to be a
successful and profitable leap in China
a new firm absolutely because we're
instead of having to accept other
people's I believe erroneous views as to
where their self interest lies instead
we the friend of mine i started at an
energy company based upon what we felt
we're an appropriate set of values both
in terms of dealing with people
ethically and also in terms of making
money and that's exactly what happened
okay so this is spinnaker exploration
of which you become the founding CFO
right and which becomes a public company
when in 1999 in 1999 and the key
business model as to the way you
apportion your capital investments is
it's interesting and sort of parallel
what we're talking well the whole thing
was bet based on information and that
the key problem for most companies is
not mechanical stuff or even personnel
per se it's information and it's
maintaining a free flow of information
and investing in information but there
are two ways to invest in information
one is directly by buying information
and the other is to invest in the sense
of every day treatment of your employees
who are really the sources of your
information and without their assurance
that information is valued and honesty
is valued and fairness is valued will
engage in all sorts of self-defeating
some optimization that will can
ultimately kill you because employees
like children don't care what they say
they care what you do and so unless
you're willing to do the right thing
every day and invest in an accurate
reputation inside outside firm every day
you won't get the accurate information
you won't get the cooperation and so
every time we thought about what we
should do we say well what would Enron
do when we do the reverse and it really
worked very well and it really
reinforced I mean at my attitude toward
what's possible in business did a 180
degree turn after or with spinnaker
because I proved to myself what I had
not seen in 20 years and that is you can
make good money doing the right thing
and the conclusion of your career at
spinnaker as i remember is signaled by
8th
36-hour migraine headache 48 we were
we'd gone public and one of the sources
of will call an inefficiency how about
that inefficiency in our system is that
most of the people who are investing
public money really don't have the
ability to assess corporate strategy nor
do they have the ability to assess a
management's capacity to execute the
strategy that they voice well what they
do know is where the night that you hit
your numbers and if you hit your numbers
and they buy and if you miss your
numbers they sell and so if you are a
company that constructs your numbers
knowing that you have hip pocket hidden
reserves you can always reverse whenever
you need to well there's no tension
about numbers if on the other hand you
construct forecasts which have more than
a trivial chance of being missed which
would be a fair forecast by the way a
fifty-fifty chance then you really end
up where every quarter is like a game of
Russian roulette and for many my
employees it was not true of me but many
of my employees the bulk of their liquid
net worth was in spinnaker and so I
wasn't terribly worried about the
financial effect on me but I was worried
that one of these days we're going to
miss our numbers and a lot of my fellow
employees networks would be decimated
okay ja so I we've run out of time here